>> Tucker: A VICIOUS MS-13
ATTACK IS BEING BLAMED ON
AMERICA'S IMMIGRATION LOOPHOLES,
RAMON LOPEZ, ALLEGEDLY TOOK PART
IN A AN ASSAULT ON TO NEW YORK
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS, BOTH
OF THE ALLEGED ASSAILANTS WERE
DETAINED AT THE BORDER IN 2016,
BUT SINCE THEY WERE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AT THE
TIME, THEY WERE ALLOWED TO
SETTLE IN THIS COUNTRY WHILE
AWAITING DEPORTATION, OF COURSE
THEY WERE NEVER DEPORTED, NOBODY
EVER IS.
WITHOUT THAT CATCH AND RELEASE
POLICY, THE CRIME LIKELY WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED.
MARK MORGAN, HEAD OF THE BORDER
PATROL UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA,
DISMISSED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP,
YOU SHOULD KEEP IN MIND.
AND THANK YOU, MR. MORGAN VERY
MUCH FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
IS IT TOO MUCH TO SAY THAT THIS
IS A REAL-WORLD EXAMPLE OF WHAT
CAN HAPPEN IF YOU HAVE A
DYSFUNCTIONAL IMMIGRATION
POLICY?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
TUCKER, AND I THINK YOU SAID IT
RIGHT.
IT IS ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION
PROCESS IN THIS COUNTRY UP CROSS
THE BOARD IS BROKE.
THIS IS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
IF THEY COULD LOOK THIS UP, THE
FLORA'S DECISION, THAT IS WHAT
MANDATES UNITED STATES BORDER
PATROL TO RELEASE MINORS.
ONLY A FEW A DAY, AND THEY HAVE
TO RELEASE THEM REGARDLESS IF
THEY HAVE BEEN PROPERLY VETTED
TO, OR IF THEY HAVE A PARENT IN
THE UNITED STATES, THEY HAVE TO
BE RELEASED INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A JUDICIAL
RULING, A COURT CAME UP WITH
THAT DECISION, HAS CONGRESS EVER
ACTED ON IT?
SINCE CLEARLY THAT IS CRAZY, WHY
DOES THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
NOT FIX IT?
>> THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION,
ANOTHER REASON OF ME BREAKING MY
SILENCE, BECAUSE CONGRESS COULD
FIX THIS IN 5 MINUTES IF THEY
WANTED TO.
BEFORE HE WAS A CHEAPO BORDER
PATROL I WAS WITH THE FBI.
AND I SUPERVISED MS-13 GANG
FORCE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE USED TO CATCH AMONGST A
SURVEILLANCE WIRES AND THEY
WOULD LAUGH, MS-13 GANG MEMBERS
WOULD LAUGH AT HOW EASY IT WAS
TO GO BACK BETWEEN THE MEXICO
AND U.S. BORDER.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE HAD A
NUMBER OF DEBATES ON THE SHOW
WITH DEMOCRATS WHO SAY THERE IS
SOMETHING BIGOTED ABOUT
CRITICIZING MS-13 AND SOMEBODY
WHO HAS WORKED TO APPREHEND
MS-13, HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND?
>> THAT IS RIDICULOUS, I KNOW
THAT THIS MAY BE CONTROVERSIAL,
BUT WHEN THE PRESIDENT REFERRED
TO THEM AS ANIMALS, I ABSOLUTELY
SAID THAT IS CORRECT.
THOSE MS-13 MEMBERS, AND I CAN
TELL YOU, AGAIN, BECAUSE I HAVE
WORKED AND I UP AND THERE IS A
CHIEF, I CAN TELL YOU THAT I'VE
BEEN TO THE DETENTION FACILITY
IS WHERE I'VE WALKED UP TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE SO-CALLED
MINOR 17 AND UNDER AND LOOKED AT
THEIR EYES, TUCKER, AND I SAID,
THAT IS A SOON TO BE MS-13 GANG
MEMBER, IT IS UNEQUIVOCAL.
>> Tucker: THEIR VICTIMS ARE
MOSTLY IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES?
>> THAT IS ANOTHER UNTOLD STORY
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
THEY ABSOLUTELY PRAY ON THEIR
OWN.